[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi there.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and you're watching
The Developer Show, a
special Google I/O 2016
on-location edition.
In this episode, we're
going to check out
the cool stuff going on at the
Google Cloud Platform tent.
Now, I'm about to play
Query It with Felipe.
And just, before we start,
I'd like to ask the crowd,
is Felipe going to win?
SPEAKER: No.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What about me?
[CROWD CHEERING]
The crowd's on my side.
FELIPE HOFFA: Get ready.
GDELT. All the
news in the world.
Everything that is
happening from 30 years ago
until the last fifteen minutes.
What country, besides
the United States,
was mentioned with Greece
the most last year?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, yeah.
I know that one.
FELIPE HOFFA: [INAUDIBLE].
They're close.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Turkey?
FELIPE HOFFA: I think
you may be right, but.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You're
just screwing with me now.
Don't let me win, Felipe.
FELIPE HOFFA:
They're super close.
SQL query.
Analyzing all of the
news from last year.
This is a real-time query.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is so cool.
It's also beautiful.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
I--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I mean, the cool
part is how fast it's querying.
It's also beautiful.
FELIPE HOFFA: I do
love this animation.
But to analyze-- analyze
in thirty seconds.
Over a million.
Germany.
CROWD: Turkey.
FELIPE HOFFA: [SHOUTING] Oh!
Turkey was the second one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Now I'm here with Bret.
Still in the Google
Cloud Platform tent.
And we're going to take a
look at the Cloud Vision API.
But first, we need
to take a few photos.
All right, Bret.
So this is the Cloud Vision
API detecting facial emotions.
Tell me all about it.
BRET MCGOWEN: So
the Vision API does
a lot of things, one of
which is emotion detection.
So it's actually
analyzing these faces,
and it's going to
give us a likelihood
of different emotions.
So joy, sorrow,
anger, and surprise.
And it does it by looking at
different facial features,
so like, where your nose
is, position of your mouth,
position of your
ears, and so forth.
So we can see in
these it's going
to color it appropriately.
So this is very
likely to be joy.
So you can see that
it's, like, yellow on it.
This is angry, so it's red,
and sorrow, so it's blue.
So our-- our photos are
starting to come in now.
You can see--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
an angry Timothy.
BRET MCGOWEN: I would say that
is very likely to be angry.
Surprised.
And then, what is this one?
Joy.
All right.
So it's actually zooming in.
And you can see all these
dots are actually spots
recognized by the Vision API.
So midpoint between the
nose and eyes, and so forth.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's amazing.
BRET MCGOWEN: And there's
a whole lot of things
that the Vision API does.
It can analyze images to
see what's in a photo.
It can tell you,
for example, this
is a photo of a dog, or
furniture, or a chair.
It can do text extraction,
so you can upload an image
and it can read street
signs, for example.
Take a picture of
a page in a book,
and it'll give
you the text back.
An interesting thing is it
can do safe-search protection.
So you can upload an image, tell
you if it's not safe for work.
It's powered by the
same algorithms--
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really useful.
BRET MCGOWEN: Yeah.
It's powered by
the same algorithms
that powers Google
SafeSearch on the web.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
BRET MCGOWEN: So
you can plug them
in to anything that can
make a rest API call.
So you can use it
from your Android app,
you can use it from your
web app, from your iOS app.
We also have speech API.
Which, if you use, like, Google
Now, and as you talk, like,
it sort of transcribes
your text as you go.
So we have a version
of speech API.
We've got a prediction
API, translate API,
and a lot more on the way.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thanks, Bret.
BRET MCGOWEN: Yeah, you bet.
[MUSIC PLAYING]